and Sara Bareilles joins us now Sara
good morning thanks for being with us
thanks for having me that was that was
best who the lead character in the show
who was played by Brittany O'Grady was
really terrific it was a young singer
dealing with her own self-doubt she goes
through this I'm interested because the
title of the show comes from a song that
you wrote early on that was supposed to
be on your first album but basically
folks told you no it's it's not good
enough and you you put it away but what
led you to go back to it you know it's
so funny I love the poetic justice of
this part of the story but we were I was
in conversation with my partner Jesse
Nelson who also created waitress with me
and we were talking about a theme song
for the show and wanting to kind of
encapsulate the you know the thesis
statement and I was trying to write
something and just really couldn't quite
crack the code and remembered that this
song has been laying dormant for 15
years and I shared it with her and she's
like this is you know perfect and so
yeah it feels like this song was just
waiting all these years to find a home I
guess did you find it's interesting when
you go back and look at something like
that you go well you know this was
actually a pretty good song it becomes
really clear how fixated I was on
everyone else's opinions very early on I
have I still struggle with that but I
you know we as a young artist you're
really looking for validation outside
yourself to keep getting permission to
sort of show up as you are so that's the
journey we see best go on that's the
journey I've gone on and so many of my
friends and colleagues right you
mentioned Jesse Nelson he wrote waitress
with you working together on this show
as well you'd never written a musical
before you've never written it for a TV
show before it is it harder is it the
same yeah no they are so hard and
they're very different this was was so
deeply challenging in ways that I was
not prepared for and I think it has to
do with just the pace
television there's such an incredible
volume of material to create and to
produce the you know the technical sides
the logistics of getting a production
shoot up and running thank God we had
wonderful people working with us but I
really wasn't you know aware of the
magnitude of trying to get something
like this off the ground you've talked
about dealing with anxiety before how
are you how are you dealing with it
through this pandemic not well you know
every day is different I I haven't had
sort of anxiety spikes like this since I
was in my early 20s and so it's really
it's it's a strange thing to return to
territory like that but I cope with a
lot of therapy and meditation and I
think really just coming back to the
fact that we are in times that we could
not have prepared for so I'm trying to
just be a good student right now and
kind of learn how to cope day to day and
I'm getting better than I was but it's
not a straight line for sure
and you lost someone you work closely
with unweight Resaca Lina Cordero the
actor who died of coronavirus just
recently can you tell us what you what
your best memories of him are all of
them I think you know when we talk about
Nick amongst friends and our community
it's no one has anything negative to say
about him he was deeply kind really
really talented loving funny buoyant
personality and but just a real a kind
man
so I my heart breaks for his wife and
son Amanda and Elvis and but we will
honor his memory so grateful I got to
know him and you see that he's
galvanized you know his story has
galvanized this beautiful outpouring of
love and support and and hope in
community so that's at least a good
thing sir you were you were playing the
lead and in waitress in London on the
west end when Cora
shut everything down are you worried
about when theater will finally get back
to normal again
oh man I'm desperate for you know some
sense of normalcy and not part of you
know my life but I I think what I know
is that the appetite for coming back
together we've learned how what a flimsy
surrogate the screens are for being in a
room with each other I miss people so
much and I think the appetite for
theatre will be through the roof and I
think you know hopefully we'll just be
able to do the work we need to do while
we have this time and prepare for how to
make it safe and and inclusive all right
Sara Bareilles flimsy surrogate the
screens are I think that's a wonderful
expression it's so true thank you so
much for being with us this morning you
can you can watch the first three
episodes of little voice on Apple TV
plus